sur le 144 et sur le 129 rapports
préparatoire à la LPM
c'est le Président c'est un plaisir
toujours renouvelé de vous accueillir
ici en tant que président directeur
général de Dassault Aviation merci
d'avoir accepté cette audition sur le
évidemment qui va porter sur le projet
de LPM que nous examinerons dans trois
semaines en commission mais qui d'Orient
déjà fait l'objet d'un travail
approfondi de la part de nos de nos
rapporteurs je rapporterai moi-même ce
texte mais avec le concours de toutes
celles et ceux qui suivent notamment à
travers les budgets le déroulement de
cette procédure
la semaine dernière donc nous avions une
audition qui réunissait les trois
groupes représentatifs des industries de
défense du phase J4 mais nous avons
souhaité vous entendre pour que vous
puissiez exprimer votre opinion
d'industriel sur ce projet de texte en
effet
si bien évidemment nous avons été
sensibles à une annonce quand même
conséquente 413 milliards ce n'est pas
tout à fait rien dans la situation de
nos finances publiques mais il reste que
de nombreux points nous interroge sur
lesquels vos éclairages sont d'autant
plus utiles que nous avons eu par le
passé et nous comptons bien l'avoir
aujourd'hui l'occasion d'apprécier votre
franchise et le recul stratégique de
votre analyse de vos analyses un effort
substantiel est donc prévu en matière
d'équipements 268 milliards d'euros son
programmés sur la période 2024 2030
c'était 172 milliards d'euros sur la
période précédente donc on voit quand
même un véritable effort et pourtant
d'ores et déjà on voit bien que des
étalement de programme sont prévus en
particulier cela vous concerne
directement il est prévu que la cible de
rafale de l'armée de l'air à l'horizon
2030 passe de 185 à 137 appareils ce qui
n'est pas une mince affaire
lorsqu'on a interrogé le ministre sur ce
sujet il nous a dit que ces étalement
visaient à privilégier la cohérence sur
la masse c'est la grande thématique
ministérielle de sur cette loi en
d'autres termes qu'on vient de consentir
une progression moins rapide du nombre
de certains équipements au profit d'une
amélioration de leur disponibilité ça
peut s'entendre d'une manière générale
mais votre point de vue sur les rafales
est évidemment très intéressante et vous
nous direz qu'elle analyse vous faites
de cette idée et quels sont du reste les
conséquences les conséquences
industrielles que ces étalements vont
avoir sur vous votre entreprise et d'une
manière générale sur nos forces
par ailleurs l'inflation l'inflation qui
est de retour a fait peser une
incertitude très importante sur la
portée de l'effort consenti je rappelle
que sur les 413 milliards le ministre
consent à nous dire que d'ores et déjà
c'est près de 30 milliards qui
disparaîtrait dans le cadre de
l'inflation ce qui évidemment aura une
une conséquence et donc il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui paraît-il
sont engagés par le ministère des armées
pour en limiter les effets notamment la
hausse du report de charge là aussi nous
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez on
regarde aussi avec une certaine méfiance
le retour de la fameuse bosse que la LPM
Parly c'était justement efforcée de
gommer et donc en tant qu'industriel
quel est votre opinion sur cette
augmentation attendue du report de
charge est-ce que ce procédé est
véritablement soutenable
s'agissant de du des modalités de
financement de certains programmes
majeurs notamment du porte-avion de
nouvelle génération nous avons appris
que les industriels étaient appelés à
financer sur leur trésorerie une partie
du coût de leur développement et pour le
pancré c'est pas totalement neutre
puisqu'on parle d'un milliard ce qui
n'est pas une petite affaire et donc on
souhaiterait savoir si des mécanismes de
ce type ont été prévus dans le domaine
aérien et dans l'affirmative si ceci
résulte bien d'un accord équilibré avec
l'État en d'autres termes si vous avez
si vous si vous avez consenti ou vous
auriez consenti à cet effort plus
généralement nous avons interrogé les
groupements de labilité dès la semaine
passée sur l'affirmation du ministre que
l'étalement des programmes s'expliquait
aussi par l'impossibilité pour notre
BITD de produire à des cadences plus
élevées
plus d'un alors donc qu'en est-il pour
Dassault en particulier dans un contexte
de remarquable succès à l'export est-ce
que ces succès à l'export ont une
véritable conséquence sur le rythme de
production des avions qui nous seront
nécessaires au cours de cette LPM en
d'autres termes pour parler clairement
est-ce que vous pourriez produire plus
si l'état vous le demandez ou s'il est à
vous en passer commande et est-ce que
ceci aurait une incidence sur les coûts
unitaires des avions à ce sujet du reste
je voudrais aussi nous étions ensemble à
Mont-de-Marsan et sur les 13 milliards
qui nous interrogent beaucoup on se pose
la question de savoir à quoi
correspondent ces 13 milliards extra
budgétaires alors pour une partie on les
saisit bien les ventes de les ventes de
fréquences le service de santé
l'immobilier mais il y a eu une petite
phrase du président de la République qui
disait qu'on allait demander des efforts
aux industriels sur les programmes des
gens engagés donc en d'autres termes
avez-vous déjà consenti des réductions
de tarifs sur les commandes qui vous
sont déjà passées ça nous éclairera sur
le financement des 7 milliards qui va
bien falloir trouver
enfin bien évidemment on souhaiterait
profiter de votre présence ici pour que
vous nous fassiez un point sur l'état
d'avancement du SCAF dont on parle moins
mais qui est quand même une partie
importante de nos réflexions notre
commission suit attentivement ce
programme mené en collaboration en
coopération avec l'Allemagne et
l'Espagne on vous avait du reste entendu
spécifiquement sur ce sujet lorsqu'il y
a eu un moment de blocage Airbus et
Dassault sont parvenus à un accord sur
la phase 1 B en fin d'année dernière
mais vous pourrez nous dire où vous en
êtes quels sont les avancées de cette
phase des étapes à venir les éventuels
sujets qui restent en suspens
éventuellement les questions relatives à
l'exportation du futur avion
je profite pour préciser à mes collègues
que nous avons normalement
normalement une rencontre avec la
commission de la défense d'Allemagne qui
vient à Évreux le 1er juin et nous
sommes invités avec nos collègues
députés et pour l'instant je ne suis pas
noyé par les demandes de participation
donc je lance un appel général car on se
plaint assez que le dialogue avec les
Allemands est assez compliqué mais s'ils
viennent en France et qu'on n'est pas là
pour les accueillir je crois qu'il y a
déjà 6 ou 8 députés qui seront là je
voudrais pas perdre la face en étant
tout seul ou avec un collègue pour
l'instant il y en a un qui s'est
manifesté donc le 1er juin à Évreux tout
est organisé y compris un somptueux
dîner à l'Assemblée nationale le soir
pour les fêter c'était une parenthèse
mais elle est importante je vous
rappelle président que cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo et
qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur le
site du Sénat en effet ce sujet de la
LPM intéresse bien au-delà de la
communauté de défense et évidemment nous
nous en réjouissons je vous propose de
faire comme vous en avez l'habitude
lorsque vous venez devant la commission
une présentation globale sur l'ensemble
de ces questions puis après nous
entamerons un dialogue avec les mes
collègues qui auront certainement des
questions complémentaires à vous poser
sur le Président vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
bonjour à vous tous d'abord merci de de
m'accueillir ce matin pour ce sujet bien
très très important qui est la loi de
programmation militaire qui je le
rappelle est un outil que beaucoup nous
ont envie puisque on arrive à programmer
sur sur une période finalement assez
longue même si c'est jamais assez long
pour prévoir le futur et ça évite de
faire du budgétaire année après année
donc il est important que cette
reprogrammation militaire puisse être
débattue et je l'espère voter
avant de démarrer sur les questions que
que vous vous posez et que je pense
qu'on pourra reprendre
dans un jeu de questions réponses je
voudrais d'abord comme j'ai la chance
d'être dans une face à une commission
qui s'occupe à la fois de défense et
d'affaires étrangères c'est pas
totalement non lié en réalité je voulais
juste vous donner moi mon impression du
moment je pense que on est sorti d'un
monde bipolaire avant la chute du mur et
puis après on avait un monde unifié dans
la paix on a maintenant un monde qui est
loin d'être bipolaire alors on a
toujours d'un côté
je parle assez franchement les
Américains avec leurs alliés dont nous
faisons partie en tout cas
tel que je le comprends je remets pas en
cause mais dans le reste du monde que je
sillonne c'est souvent il y a pas un
bloc
russe voir chinois il y a des gens qui
sont aussi dans une zone qui veulent ni
un alignement sur les américains ni un
alignement sur les Russes ces gens sont
assez nombreux en réalité sur terre si
vous prenez les pays conciliables assez
régulièrement vous avez bien sûr l'Inde
qui cherche à être
j'oserais pas utiliser le monde en
aligné mais j'utiliserai quand même
parce que c'est celui qui ressemble le
plus même si pas comparer le non
alignement des lias 50 60 ans au long de
la Ligue bande aujourd'hui la guerre
n'étant pas la même la période n'étant
pas la même malgré tout vous avez donc
l'Inde vous avez une partie des pays
d'Asie qui veulent pas être
instrumentalisés dans un potentiel
conflit entre les Américains et la Chine
et donc qui cherche des voies un petit
peu intermédiaires vous avez une grande
partie voir la totalité de l'Amérique du
Sud ce qui est pas rien non plus dans le
continent américain
vous avez une grande partie de l'Afrique
avec du plus et du moins certains sa
ligne sur les Russes d'autres sont pas
alignés d'autres voilà donc on n'a pas
un monde bipolaire je pense que c'est
très important de le comprendre
ensemble car ça ça justifie un centre de
choses la deuxième chose c'est que
j'entends toujours certaines
pensées très très forte de dire les
industriels à un moment français tirent
profit de la guerre en Ukraine alors en
ce qui me concerne d'assovation 0 celui
qui tire profit de la guerre en Ukraine
ça s'appelle les États-Unis d'Amérique
point il y en a pas d'autres en tout cas
en ce qui concerne nous les avions de
combat
prenez tout de les annonces tous les
contrats même en Tchécoslovaquie très
récemment la volonté d'acheter du F35
c'est sûrement pas des pays qui achètent
j'étais en Suisse hier F35 la Finlande
F-35 la Pologne je crois pas utiliser
appelé acheter des avions européens même
des avions coréens donc vous voyez tous
ceux qui disent à la radio à la télé
ce conflit alors c'est beaucoup des ONG
en réalité
soutient etc c'est pas vrai
c'est le premier point deuxième point
donc en Europe pas beaucoup de salut un
peu la Grèce mais je dirais plus que
c'est par problématique turque vous
voyez là c'est encore un autre sujet qui
est un petit peu un des indépendant de
la de la problématique ukrainienne
heureusement on a quand même un pays
comme la Croatie qui vient vers la
France pour essayer d'eux en ce qui est
concerne etc la deuxième remarque que je
voulais faire c'est que ces pays qui
sont pas alignés voient quand même
encore dans la France et je dis bien
dans la France j'ai pas dit dans
l'Europe dans la France une position un
petit peu plus moduler par rapport à cet
alignement systématique et fort sur les
Américains que de certains pays d'Europe
et donc ils viennent chercher non
seulement la capacité
opérationnelle il faut que nous avions
que l'on développe soit voilà et le
Rafale est reconnu comme étant une
capacité opérationnelle et un désaccord
stratégiques avec la France qui offre
cette singularité d'être à la fois
alliée des dans le camp occidental mais
en ayant une voix un petit peu
particulière tel qu'on a pu le voir
aussi il y a des décennies avec la
politique générale de Gaulle
donc ça c'est par contre ça nous
favorise ça nous favorise indépendamment
de la guerre en Ukraine c'était vrai
avant surtout d'ailleurs les grands
contrats qu'on a pu passer à
l'exportation ce sont fait avant la
guerre en Ukraine donc le Moyen-Orient
vous l'avez vu l'Egypte le
Qatar et le gros contrat avec les
Émirats à réunis relève de cette volonté
de d'être un petit peu plus
indépendant des Américains l'Inde
l'Indonésie là c'est on va vers le plus
loin le président de la République c'est
beaucoup intéressé s'intéresse beaucoup
à cette partie du monde c'est pas un
hasard et ces pays-là veulent pas non
plus se faire d'une certaine manière
instrumentaliser voilà donc je voulais
juste démarrer par ça pour bien qu'on
comprenne la manière dont nous nous
évoluons en la main dans la main avec
forcément le pouvoir exécutif d'abord
parce que je le rappelle
l'exportation de matériel de guerre est
interdite sauf autorisation
toujours le rappeler et donc c'est bien
dans cette logique que nous que nous
opérons à l'étranger sous couvert de
l'État pour revenir à la loi de
programmation militaire il n'empêche
donc pas moi que nos forces armées les
nôtres les Françaises sont mis à
contribution n'ont pas directement dans
la guerre mais en tout cas en bordure de
de ce conflit pour soutenir les efforts
de soutien à nos pays européens en
bordure de d'Ukraine et donc la première
chose que que nous avons fait c'est bien
sûr d'être réactif sur le soutien
opérationnel je pense que c'est une de
vos questions la manière dont l'État et
les armées ont organisé le la
verticalisation
du soutien et quelque chose de
primordial et donc nous
ceux-ci se fait sur le Rafale depuis
déjà de nombreuses années et porte ses
fruits petit à petit et donc vous avez
des disponibilités contractuelles qui
qui ont augmenté on est capable de
piloter mieux l'ensemble de la Supply
chaîne ce qui reste dans la
disponibilité opérationnelle plus
difficile par rapport à la disponibilité
contractuelle c'est que vous avez des
avions qui sont en rétrophyte dans des
standards vous avez etc des fois il
manque un sérum de pièces de rechange et
donc c'est c'est pour ça que vous avez
une différence entre la disponibilité
opérationnelle et la disponibilité
contractuelle disponibilité
contractuelle en France et du même ordre
de grandeur que les disponibilités que
nous avons à l'autre bout du monde
grosso modo si vous prenez un Mirage
2000 dans un certain nombre de pays où
nous opérons la disponibilité elle est à
90% le Rafale aujourd'hui à plus de 90%
dans les pays étrangers et des à 90%
autour de 90% pour la France je dirais
bien en disponibilité contractuelle
après il y a des avions qui sont
utilisés pour pour faire autre chose
donc ça ça c'est important donc dans la
remontée à venir je pense que les
efforts sur le soutien sont terriblement
importants mais je pense pas qu'on est
beaucoup pas gagné pour avoir des des
avions opérationnels sur ces postes là
alors j'en viens au débat principal
d'abord on a nous deux grandes activités
dans la future loi de programmation le
Rafale qui qui est l'objet de vos
questions principalement mais il faut
pas oublier la partie marine alors pas
tellement sur le porte-avions puisque
les avions devant aller sur le
porte-avion sont déjà là 41 avions ont
été livrés à la Marine nationale 41
rafales mais tout ce qui est
surveillance donc la poursuite de la
modernisation de l'Atlantique 2
la livraison des avions de surveillance
de guerre électrolink qu'on a appelé
Archange qui rentreront dans la loi de
programmation je crois trois avions
la livraison des avions de surveillance
maritime à base de Falcon 2000 qui
seront liv
dans cette loi de programmation
militaire aussi avec des échéances qui
sont à confirmer au titre de cette loi
de programmation
militaire en tout cas une cible de 12
avions pour la pour la surveillance
maritime voilà donc ce deuxième volet
que je cite rapidement
et très important pour les rafales vous
l'avez cité 137 pour l'armée de l'air
en réalité je rappelle nous sommes en
train de livrer ce qu'on a appelé la 4
T2 qui a été bloquée pendant des années
des années et là je tiens à le rappeler
devant vous comme je le fais
régulièrement
cette cat T2 qui a été décalée elle n'a
jamais été décalée pour faire passer
l'export en premier elle a été décalée
pour des raisons exclusivement
budgétaires et de paiement etc donc ce
retard de livraison
pris vers l'armée de l'air décidé par
vous d'une certaine manière puisque
c'est l'Assemblée nationale et vous-même
qui est sous l'impulsion du gouvernement
c'était avant à accepter ce décalage on
va dire comme ça
ne fait que maintenant on va livrer ses
avions là comme on a pris 12 avions sur
le stock français pour faire la Grèce il
y a eu une commande complémentaire de 12
avions ce qui fait que les 28 de la 4 T2
plus les 12 à remplacer qui fait 40
avions un premier avion a été livré
conformément au contrat l'année dernière
en fin d'année dernière et maintenant
nous rentrons dans la livraison de cette
tranche qui est qui sera à hauteur de
très avion cette année en 2023
c'est pas encore la LPM mais presque et
très avion en 2024 nous avions 2025 et
un avion en 2026
clôturera les avions français que nous
avons dans notre carnet de commandes et
que nous et nous avons depuis bien
longtemps
en attendant normalement en 2023 une
commande de 42 avions devrait arriver
donc c'est 30 avions qui étaient prévus
de longue date mais décalé et décalé et
décalé et décalé à la droite plus 12
avions de compensation sur le les 12
avions qui ont été vendus à la Croatie
car je rappelle que en Croatie c'est 12
avions d'occasion tirés de l'Armée de
l'Air français ce qui a été
livré donc c'est 42 avions devraient
donner l'objet d'un contrat dont les
livraisons sont en cours de discussion
mais le gros des livraisons
arrivant plutôt en en à partir de 2029
et on discute d'avoir quelques avions à
livrer un petit peu avant c'est-à-dire
en
27 et 28
je peux pas vous en dire beaucoup plus
puisque le contrat n'est pas signé il
est en cours de de discussion en
parallèle donc de ces livraisons de
production et je rappelle que nous nous
pourrions livrer plutôt c'est répondre à
l'une de vos questions nous avons
augmenté les chaînes de fabrication on
est passé de moins de 1 à 3 alors on
aurait préféré que il y ait un lissage
au moment où on en avait besoin et que
la charge de travail commençait très
basse il y a deux trois ans
ça augmente grâce à l'export ça va
continuer pour la France à raison de un
par mois mais nous sommes capables
d'augmenter les chaînes de fabrication
simplement il faut un délai pour le
faire parce que nos sous-traitants en ce
moment on souffre beaucoup il y a du ce
qu'on appelle de la montée en charge
dans tous les dans tous les secteurs de
l'industrie comme vous le savez le
paradoxe même s'il y a encore beaucoup
de chômeurs c'est que les industriels du
mal encore à recruter c'est pas tout à
fait le cas chez Dassault mais c'est
parce que on a plutôt des bonnes
conditions chez nous mais c'est vrai
dans beaucoup de PME répartis sur les
territoires français je rappelle que
quand on quand on fait un Rafale on fait
vivre plus de 400 entreprises réparties
sur les territoires français c'est plus
difficile pour eux pour embaucher ils
ont aussi à faire face à un centre de
difficultés le prix de l'énergie enfin
je vous rappelle tout ça
et et ça donne une fragilité sur la
Supply chaîne aujourd'hui qui fait que
il faut quand même prévoir à l'avance
quand on a des montées en charge ceci
dit on est capable de monter en charge
en parallèle de la production donc je
voulais dire qu'il y a aussi le
développement donc le
l'état poursuit son effort de
modernisation du Rafale le Rafale
finalement il est resté à la pointe des
capacités opérationnelles en réponse au
retour d'expérience de nos militaires et
maintenant de ceux de l'export grâce à
l'implémentation de standard successifs
on en est au standard 4 qui est en cours
de développement qui seront livrés dans
les dans les années qui viennent en
trois parties et puis on aura au cours
de cette LPM une la définition d'un
futur standard 5 qui sera d'ailleurs
compatible et préparatoire de ce qu'on
appelle la composante nucléaire
aéroportée qui sera
renouvelé
à des dates que que l'État doit vous
communiquer voilà donc c'est c'est ce
parallèle en développement est très
important et on aura très certainement
et là on est un peu en
compétition un avion de patrouille
maritime aussi à développer que nous
nous proposons à partir d'un Falcon 10x
une fois que j'ai dit ça ça
s'adresse le paysage en ce qui nous
concerne de la loi de programmation
militaire on y rajoute donc tout ce qui
est recherche et technologies en amont
un certain nombre d'études en amont
le programme Scave dont vous avez parlé
qui jouera rappelle est un pour
l'instant d'un des commandes d'études
donc nous sommes dans la phase 1 B cette
phase 1 B a démarré en début d'année
avec nos amis allemands et espagnol donc
c'est en particulier en ce qui concerne
le pilier 1 celui de l'avion le cœur de
du développement se fait à Saint-Cloud
dans notre bureau d'études où on nous
accueillons nos amis des des équipes
partenaires donc ce conseille de
définition est en cours il se fait en
parallèle avec ce qu'on appelle pour les
experts le pilier 0 le pilier 0 c'est là
où nos opérationnels des trois pays
continuent de regarder les architectures
de ce qui pourrait être le besoin en
opérationnel poste 2040 donc
nous nous travaillons sur les
technologies en adéquation avec ce que
les militaires et nous-mêmes simulons
dans ce dans ce pilier zéro je ne
parlerai pas des autres piliers moteurs
etc sauf si vous avez des questions
puisque d'autres sont très directement
en charge alors juste pour rappeler nous
notre objectif c'est de faire voler un
démonstrateur il faudra encore passer un
contrat qui s'appelle la phase 2 je
rappelle que quand on a fait le neurone
et qu'on était six pays donc beaucoup de
sociétés autour de table
il a été contractualisé
de la décision d'y aller jusqu'à
jusqu'au à la campagne de ces envol un
seul contrat là c'est à chaque fois donc
évidemment ça va nous exposer à
rediscuter à chaque fois avec nos
partenaires et comme vous le savez nos
partenaires sont très dépendants aussi
de ce que veulent leurs autorités c'est
normal et leur parlement d'où la
référence au parlement allemand dont
vous avez fait monsieur le Président qui
évidemment quelque chose d'important
puisque très souvent nos amis allemands
nous disent mais nous on veut bien mais
c'est le parlement allemand le Bundestag
qui etc bon j'ai dit ben nous aussi on a
un parlement qui de temps en temps a
aussi le droit de s'exprimer
voilà donc ça s'appelle l'équilibre
la parité je sais pas comment on peut
l'appeler voilà donc ça se ça se
développe bien
moi je suis plus prudent je suis très je
suis très enthousias si il s'agit de
faire voler un démonstrateur coopération
pas coopération quand on l'a fait avec
le neurone ça c'est très bien passé
savoir maintenant comment on va
développer un programme
capacité opérationnelle on en est pas là
on est en préparation donc je pourrais
pas vous répondre à ces questions-là qui
à mon avis sont largement après 2040
quand vous regardez la vitesse à
laquelle les choses s'enclenchent bon
2040 c'est le c'est la c'est la date
très optimiste d'ailleurs le mini je
pense s'est exprimé il y a peu de temps
pour dire que bien sûr le Rafale va
vivre au moins 30 ans en parallèle avec
le NGF donc c'est quelque chose voyez
qui va être chaud du du très long terme
et c'est pour ça qu'il est important de
continuer à moderniser le Rafale en
fonction des besoins de nos
opérationnels pour le faire vivre dans
les années de 2030 jusqu'à poste 2050
sur l'Europe un mot quand même on a
obtenu des commandes de la part de la
Commission européenne ce qui est
évidemment nouveau sur le ce qu'on
appelle le fait le Fonds européen de
défense c'est compliqué de
contractualiser avec l'Europe
communautaire on l'a quand même eu c'est
de il faut mettre un peu d'argent sur la
table c'est-à-dire que l'Europe ne
couvre pas les dépenses des industriels
ce qui est d'une certaine manière en
rupture par rapport à ce que les
sociétés américaines ont sont quand même
le gros concurrents je pense que on est
nous concurrents de nos amis américains
qui eux sont entièrement couverts de
leurs dépenses par l'État fédéral
et en plus de ça pour certains de mes de
mes collègues qui ont dû vous le dire
l'Europe fait la place aux compagnies
américaines contre des compagnies
européennes donc de temps en temps on
peut se poser quand même la question de
où va l'argent européen payé par les
Européens dans le cadre de la défense
voilà mais en ce qui nous concerne on a
obtenu ce que l'on souhaitait sur ce
Fonds européen de défense donc on n'est
pas contrairement à ce que certains
laissent penser complètement contre
l'Europe si elle va dans le bon sens
mais il faut vraiment y travailler pour
arriver à obtenir
ce que l'on veut je rappelle juste d'un
point de vue industrie taxonomie que
même si la taxonomie sociale donc la
stigmatisation des industries de défense
en Europe
a été mis de côté ils n'ont pas que il
reste à Bruxelles et sur l'ensemble des
du Parlement européen une impression de
dire que c'est mal d'être dans
l'industrie de défense
alors quand on dit ça on donne la main
au bilatéral dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui n'existe plus c'est-à-dire
chose américain ce qui est évident en
Europe soit
à ceux qui seront contre voilà donc
potentiellement nos ennemis donc je
pense qu'il est quand même encore du
travail de nous tous vous surtout et
nous derrière pour dire mettre de
l'argent dans l'industrie de défense en
Europe c'est pas une mauvaise chose
quand on voit le contexte
international il vaut mieux que les
armes soient aux mains des démocrates
plutôt qu'elles soient aux mains des
dictateurs pourvu que tout ça soit
contrôlé on est bien d'accord sur le sur
le sujet contrôle on ne vend pas des
armes à n'importe qui c'est pas moi qui
le décide c'est l'état
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
propos liminaire
si président pour l'ensemble de ces
précisions
on va je donner la parole aux différents
rapporteurs de ces programmes on va pas
commencer par le 146 Cédric Perrin
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président l'avantage avec
vous c'est que en général vous répondez
aux questions et donc comme on a un peu
tous des fois les mêmes questions pour
les répéter pour qu'on essaie d'avoir
une réponse
forcément mais j'ai quand même quelques
questions qui me qui me viennent
évidemment en plus de ce que vous avez
déjà c'est lequel vous avez répondu
notamment sur les cadences et sur les
sur les calendriers il y en a une
notamment qui consiste à peut-être avoir
un peu plus d'informations sur le
calendrier de la l'arrivée du nouveau
standard F5
vous avez dit que on devait se remettre
au gouvernement pour les calendriers
mais peut-être vous pouvez vous en dire
plus et comment surtout se positionne
dans cette dans ce dispositif le le
neuron qui était quand même un sujet que
vous avez évoqué mais qui a été
également une belle une belle opération
depuis le début des années des années
2000 comment est-ce qu'il se situe
qu'est-ce que vous que faut-il penser de
l'amendement F5 du ministre à
l'Assemblée nationale sur LPM et surtout
comment est-ce qu'il sera financé
par ailleurs ce que vous pouvez aller
au-delà de trois appareils ça a été dit
tout à l'heure par mois
obtenu notamment voulait pas évoquer
mais des contraintes en matière de de
fournitures de matières premières chez
dans la chaîne des sous-traitants vous
avez parlé des ressources humaines mais
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui de la chaîne
des matières
uegar à peut-être aussi quelques
commentaires à l'article 24 sur les
stocks qu'on voudrait obliger à faire à
mettre en œuvre dans le dans le tissu
industriel de la BITD avec
potentiellement des sanctions qui vont
en face ça aussi j'aimerais beaucoup
avoir votre avis sur cette question et
puis sur le sur le recul des rafales air
le ministre des armées en temps
progressé sur la voie de l'économie de
guerre comment est-ce que Dassault était
associé à cette discussion à cet
impératif d'économie de guerre ces
derniers temps puisque ça a été un sujet
qui était largement évoqué également
est-ce que vos relations avec le
ministère la DGA ont changé
comment est-ce que ce chantier
risque-t-il d'être lancé est-ce que vous
le pensez opérant est-ce que vous avez
des commentaires également sur le les
dispositifs des réquisitions sur le
contrôle des coupes qui prévus à
l'article 25 de la loi de programmation
militaire que nous avons auditionné un
certain nombre de représ de la BITD dans
le cadre du p146 notamment avec ma
collègue Hélène Conan Mouret qui ont
exprimé quelques réserves sur ces
dispositifs et puis monsieur le
Président j'ai été comme tout le monde
assez surpris en tout cas de la
responsabilité qu'on a fait voulu faire
porter ou qu'on veut faire porter aux
industriels sur le les étalement de
programme de 2035 lié notamment à la
capacité des industriels à répondre à la
demande en matière de production et
d'accélération des coûts des des
productions est-ce que vous en avez dit
quelques mots mais je pense que c'est un
sujet quand même très intéressant
puisque aujourd'hui on a quand même des
étalement qui ressemblent étrangement à
des renoncements et quelques mots
là-dessus pourraient nous être nous être
utile voilà j'avais beaucoup d'autres
sujets mais je crois qu'on est un peu
limité donc je m'en arrêterai
d'inversible merci Cédric Hélène Conway
Cora porter
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président merci pour vos propos
Cédric Perrin a concentré ces questions
sur le capacitaire je voudrais vous
interroger sur deux sujets d'avenir mais
qui sont également des sujets
d'actualité d'abord la décarbonation
davantage prise en compte par
l'aéronautique civile notamment par
Airbus
et un peu moins peut-être dans le
domaine militaire est-ce que vous
investissez dans ce domaine sur une
technologie particulière et va-t-elle
s'imposer finalement au domaine
militaire par souci d'indépendance
énergétique ensuite
l'intelligence artificielle pensez-vous
que la LPM y consacre une part
suffisante le développement de capacité
respective ment terrestre maritime et
aérienne a tendance à occulter les
domaines transversaux
alors le cyber est bien pris en compte
auteur de 4 milliards d'euros mais ne
faudrait-il pas accélérer aussi sur
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce
qu'elle doit être développée au sein de
programme particulier comme le Scaff par
exemple ou une manière transversale
comme une brique technologique autonome
le président combo a fait référence
oscaf dans son propos introductif moi je
voudrais vous interroger sur le
programme Tempest alors je sais que nous
en parlons depuis 2019 avec peut-être
des avis divergents sur l'avenir de ce
programme Tempest mais en même temps il
progresse et est-ce qu'il n'est pas en
train de prendre finalement un peu
d'avance sur le SCAF il associe le
Royaume-Uni l'Italie est maintenant le
Japon dans le cadre du Global combat EP
programme avec des investissements quand
même assez importants notamment dans les
briques technologiques donc est-ce
qu'une convergence avec le SCAF est
envisageable et
et peut-être souhaitable maintenant
merci merci on continue avec les
rapporteurs du 144 environnement et
prospective la politique de défense
c'est complémentaire parce qu'à la Lisa
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président
s'agissant du programme scape beaucoup a
été dit sur la dimension
franco-allemande vous avez abordé nos
partenaires espagnols mais on oublie
quand même assez communément qui sont
dans la boucle je trouve qu'on en parle
peu est-ce que vous pourriez nous faire
un point peut-être un peu plus précis
sur la coopération avec ce pays dans le
cadre de ce projet et nous rappeler ce
qui a été confié à l'industrie espagnole
et notamment à hindra systemas s'il vous
plaît ma seconde question elle a été
abordée par Cédric Perrin il y a
quelques instants c'est l'article 24 du
projet de LPM qui prévoit effectivement
des stocks de matériaux et de composants
d'intérêts stratégiques ainsi que la
priorisation de la livraison de bien et
de services aux bénéfice des armées les
représentants des groupements nous ont
indiqué ne pas être opposés à ces
dispositifs mais souhaitez être associés
à leur modalités de mise en oeuvre on
peut le comprendre quel regard
portez-vous sur cet article 24 et
dernière question il y a des études
actuellement en cours sur le futur avion
de patrouille maritimes
pourriez-vous nous donner quelques
éléments sur l'état d'avancement de ce
projet et il y a-t-il des coopérations
avec des partenaires européens je vous
remercie merci Pascal cours rapporteur
Yannick vogrenard oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président
Directeur Général ma question va donc
prolongement finalement donc précision
d'une question qui a déjà été évoquée
par Cédric Perrin donc récemment
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernements a
déposé un amendement au rapport annexé
au projet de LPM indiquant que le
standard F5 du Rafale dont il est
précisé qu'il sera développé pendant
cette programmation
comprendra notamment un drone
accompagnateur sud des travaux d'une
démonstrateur Néron lequel a notamment
été développé donc par votre entreprise
pourriez-vous nous apporter des
précisions sur ce projet notamment sur
le calendrier de conception de ce drone
accompagnateur son architecture et bien
sûr les missions qui pourraient lui être
assignées merci
merci allez on va finir avec le
178 préparation un peu des forces et là
j'ai uniquement Michel Gréau mais qui
s'exprime aussi pour Olivier sigoulotti
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président le retrait de service annoncé
des super étendards acquis par
l'Argentine en 2018 faute d'accès aux
pièces de rechange permettant de les
faire voler pose la question de cette
exportation mais c'est ici sur la
fourniture des pièces de rechange que je
souhaite vous interroger le maintien en
vol d'aéronef dont le retrait a été
décidé pose un défi logistique c'est
flotte vieillissantes dont l'entretient
programmé coûtera plus cher dépendront
de la disponibilité des pièces de
rechange nécessaire les choix de la
prochaine LPM de rallonger l'usage de
certains équipements nous incitent à
nous demander si l'industriel concerné
est en charge de la maintenance
verticalisée et bien on mesure de
fournir les pièces de rechange
nécessaire
des stocks de pièces de rechange
doivent-ils être constitués à quelle
hauteur leur financement est-il bien
prévu par la LPM avez-vous en la matière
des recommandations à formuler la
question de l'économie de guerre posée
par la LPM me semble malheureusement
faire l'économie de la problématique de
mise à disposition exceptionnelle des
liasses c'est-à-dire la documentation
technique et certains droits de
propriété intellectuelles propres à un
aéronef nos visites sur place ces
derniers mois dans les services de
soutien nous ont pourtant montré que
cette documentation est le temps qu'elle
permettrait de gagner pour être
déterminant quel serait votre position
dans ce domaine et permettez-moi aussi
monsieur le Président de poser également
la question de mon collègue Olivier
cigolotti et je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser son absence depuis mai
2019 d'assoit Aviation a sur la
maintenance hors moteur des rafales dans
le cadre du contrat Ravel la maintenance
a progressé au point que les sessions de
rafale à la Grèce n'ont pas eu de
répercussions sur la disponibilité de la
flotte depuis août 2021 safran est
titulaire du marché boléro dédié à la
maintenance des moteurs de Rafale j'ai 4
brèves questions sur la verticalisation
de la maintenance premièrement comment
les sessions à la Croatie puis à la
Serbie notamment vont-elles influencer
les contrats les flottes diminuent
changeant l'économie de la maintenance
la disponibilité va-t-elle empathie
deuxièmement quelles sont les
répercussions pour la maintenance
verticalisée des choix de cohérence
annoncés dans le cadre de la prochaine
LPM les flottes vont être réduites par
rapport aux objectifs financiers pour
respecter la cohérence avec d'autres
facteurs et sans doute en premier lieu
avec les montants des crédits
disponibles comment les contrats de
maintenance seront-ils adaptés pour
prendre en compte la surutilisation et
la suresure de la flotte réduite au nom
de la cohérence troisièmement les
facteurs que je viens d'énumérer
font-ils craint d'une explosion des
coûts de maintenance et ce pour cela que
la DGA est désormais annoncée comme
devant être parti à la
contractualisation de la maintenance
verticalisée quelle est l'appréciation
de Dassault Aviation en la matière enfin
ma quatrième question concerne le
système d'information Brasidas synthèse
de tous les systèmes d'information
existants il serait indispensable à la
mise en œuvre de l'économie de guerre
son développement et son déploiement
sont-ils bien prévus dans la prochaine
LPM commande à soiviation évolue
l'impact évalue l'impact de Brasidas sur
la maintenance merci
et bien président à vous de répondre à
tout ça
mais écoutez c'est un beau un beau
programme
on fait du travail en profondeur
il me faut mes notes quand même donc on
va commencer par F5 qui a été l'objet de
plusieurs interventions
on avait nous en tête un F5 pour les
années 2022 je vois que ça a tendance à
légèrement décaler à 2035 donc poste
LPM dans les dans les deux cas ce qui
est important c'est de bien voir qu'il y
a une synchronisation entre l'arrivée
de nouveaux types d'armement dans le
cadre de la composante nucléaire
aéroportée et le fait que l'avion
lui-même doit aussi évoluer avec son
temps c'est-à-dire renforcer son son
système d'arme en adéquation avec ce que
le retour opérationnel nous donne donc
F5 ça va être la continuation de F4 en
priorité indépendamment de des armes
dont je parle pas c'est le
le combat collaboratif qui démarre dans
le cadre du développement de F4 il faut
pas croire que le Scaff c'est le NGF
c'est le combat collaboratif le combat
qu'on a collaboratif il a déjà démarré
il faut pas non plus voilà dans le cadre
de la coopération future on continue à
développer tous ces concepts et avec un
nouvel avion en son centre mais tout ça
est déjà fait au titre enfin va être
fait au titre du Rafale donc le F5 ça
sera la poursuite du combat collaboratif
qui se développe et qui est déjà dans le
F4 grâce à des architectures de
communication que nous définissons pour
le Rafale en prenant en compte les
problématiques cyber parce que je vous
rappelle que plus on se connecte et plus
on est connecté et plus on est
vulnérable donc c'est il va falloir être
plus connecté et moins vulnérable c'est
ça la c'est ça le grand enjeu des
standards à venir et donc ça c'est fait
déjà dans F4 on aura des des
architectures résistantes à la cyber en
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais il y aura toujours le calculateur
très très proche de la mission qui sera
totalement indépendant et un serment de
calculateurs périphériques qui
permettent au pilote d'avoir un peu plus
d'informations mais qui ne se connecte
pas vers le cœur du cœur pour éviter
justement la cyber sachant que dans la
cyber tous ceux qui vous diront que il y
a pas de problème il s'affaire à 100%
sont les menteurs je vous le dis ici la
cyber c'est compliqué c'est comme dans
la guerre les pays et le bouclier jamais
jamais on vous dira que le bouclier est
100% c'est pas possible donc l'épée a
toujours un avantage donc les attaquants
cyber auront toujours un avantage donc
il faut prévoir le fait qu'il puisse
rentrer et faire en sorte qu'il ne
touche pas le cœur du cœur etc ça ça
fait partie de des définitions
d'architecture système que nous faisons
nous les les constructeurs de grandes
plateformes que ce soit les avions et
c'est pareil pour nos amis de naval
group donc ça c'est F5 F5 ça sera donc
cette continuation de ce travail et des
nouvelles armes je pense que ce schooner
the better comme on dit en anglais donc
le plus tôt on aura spécifié
ce standard et le mieux on pourra le
préparer en complément de ce qu'on fait
déjà dans F4 si c'est 2035 c'est 2035
pas moi qui décide c'est c'est l'État
sur le la suite neurone ça fait bien
longtemps je rappelle que le neurone on
l'a décidé en 2003 il a été
contractualisé quelques années après il
a volé dans ses spécifications et même
au-delà des performances qu'on nous
avait imposées
en coopération et il est rentré dans son
budget
de mémoire je crois que c'est la seule
coopération dont on peut dire qu'elle a
marché au sens à la fois du timing et du
budget d'autres coopération sûrement au
marché pour d'autres raisons mais pas
pour ces raisons-là donc on peut je le
dis très formellement on peut réussir
des coopérations pourvu qu'on prenne les
bonnes règles et pourvu qu'il y ait des
bons leaders bien donc c'est évidemment
c'est vous m'avez déjà entendu sur le
sujet mais sur le neurone le but c'était
d'avoir un drone de combat sur les les
drones je veux juste rappeler que il y a
drone et drone il y a les tout petits
drones on entend parler de ça beaucoup
en Ukraine je vais faire une remarque
d'ailleurs que si le ciel avait été pris
par un des deux belligérants un certain
nombre de drones veulent plus soit par
une bonne efficacité du solaire soit par
une bonne efficacité de la chasse qui à
ce moment-là maîtrise tout ce qui prend
le fait qu'il y ait beaucoup de drones
qui volent aujourd'hui dans le ciel
ukrainien démontre que aucun des deux
belligérants n'a pris le dessus dans le
domaine aérien ce qui pose d'ailleurs
sûrement une question à laquelle je ne
sais pas répondre et qu'il faut
s'adresser à nos amis militaires sur le
sujet
ça c'est les petits rôles il y a des
drones de surveillance vous connaissez
tous le Reaper on l'a la France en a
acheté c'est efficace à mon sens mais là
je me permets une interprétation c'est
efficace dans un milieu où on a le ciel
si vous prenez l'engagement américain
au-dessus de la Syrie et d'Irak pendant
un certain nombre dans laquelle nous
avons contribué nous les Français
j'y étais j'ai vu
vous avez des drones Reaper qui opère
parce que le ciel est sous la main
américaine
et alliés il y a pas de il y a pas des
hostiles qui passent par là et qui
tirent les droits de rippers ça marche
au dessus du ciel en Afrique parce que
il y a pas on cherche le terroriste dans
son pick-up on n'est pas en train de se
dire qu'il y a des chasseurs qui vont
venir tirer les Reaper donc tous les
avions de surveillance sont des avions
avec des ailes très longues qui volent
très lentement et qui sont des cibles de
choix les premiers jours de la guerre et
rappelez-vous en Géorgie tous les drones
ont été tirés le premier jour il y a
plus d'eau de Géorgiens au bout de moins
de 24 heures par la chasse russe à
l'époque donc c'est drôle là sont dans
un contexte très
occidental de dire on prend le ciel ce
qui on a vu dans toutes les guerres que
ce soit en Irak en Libye etc on prend le
ciel et après on fait on fait des
opérations terrestres dans lesquelles
les drones interviennent c'est drôle de
surveillance le rhodrome c'est dans ce
contexte là c'est fait à trois pays ça
s'est développé on en parlera pas ce
matin puisque
le leader étant Airbus je vous renvoie
vers un russe pour vous donner des
informations sur le sujet nous ne sommes
qu'un sous-traitants d'Airbus dans ce
domaine là
et puis il y a les drones
accompagnateurs ou les drones de combat
alors là c'est des drones qui vont
opérer
avec l'avion de combat il se trouvera
que dans un avion de combat il y a un
pilote dans l'autre il y a pas de pilote
là aussi il peut y avoir une panoplie de
drone et il peut y avoir des tout petits
drones accompagnateurs ce qu'on appelle
des Remo de carrière en anglais dans
lequel d'ailleurs dans le Scaff on a des
on a des travaux là-dessus qui ont été
confiés Airbus et puis
on a des drones de type neurones
c'est-à-dire c'est quasiment un avion de
combat qui opère en liaison avec le
Rafale donc si on parle de postes
neurone et on a toujours eu cette idée
de poursuivre dans ce domaine là on est
plutôt dans le domaine des uccales à ce
stade je sais rien vous dire de plus
parce que là c'est l'État qui qui a sous
sa main ce sujet là et on est encore
dans des dans des phases d'études et
rien n'est contractualisé
à ce stade et loin sans faut
sur la cadence 3 donc oui je confirme on
est patients kamos froid s'il fallait
passer en cadence 4 on pourrait passer
en cadence 4 vous savez la cadence faut
se méfier de ce mot là parce que on
s'est accéléré les cadences en par
exemple dans notre usine à Lille les
pièces primaires il suffit d'accélérer
un peu les machines mettre un peu plus
de personnel
faire travailler un peu plus de
sous-traitants et on augmente assez
facilement les les canons là où c'est le
plus compliqué c'est à la fin c'est ce
qu'on a à Mérignac parce que c'est
l'assemblage finale il faut des surfaces
il faut voilà et donc c'est ça qu'il
faut prévoir à l'avance pour le faire
mais rien n'est impossible
on a de la place à Mérignac et on sait
fortement augmenter ses cadences à
Mérignac
la matière première j'ai tendance à dire
pour l'instant on s'en sort
croire que l'État s'en sortira mieux que
les industriels pourquoi pas mais ce qui
est quand on fait un avion on a
maintenant des systèmes informatiques
qu'on a développé pour le civil
d'ailleurs aussi qui fait que on a une
approvisionnement qui est organisée qui
est par moment que la nature et ne faire
que des commandes de matière ça fait
longtemps qu'on le fait moi j'ai des
commandes de matière amont et j'ai mes
stocks de matière première et je demande
pas un sous à l'état je le fais parce
que je sais bien que c'est le plus long
c'est le plus difficile etc je le fais
d'autant plus que avec l'arrivée de la
guerre en Ukraine ça a tendu donc on est
à acheter de la matière première en
amont et on le fait pour nous et pour
nous sous-traitants on a mis en place
des centrales d'achat ce qui fait qu'on
compte aussi sur nos sous-traitants
parce que ça sert à rien d'avoir la
matière pour nous d'assaut si nos
sous-traitants qui doit nous livrer des
pièces sont des difficultés donc on
s'est organisé pour le faire si l'État
va nous payer des stocks il y a pas de
problème on sera d'accord
sanction sanction je sais pas ça
sanction je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
sanction je sais que c'est le grand mot
à la mode je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire je pense qu'il faut plutôt nous
aider que de nous mettre des sanctions
nous la sanction c'est si on livre pas
si on est en retard il y a des pénalités
dans les contrats etc une fois qu'on a
un contrat et sous réserve qu'on ait un
contrat c'est si on n'a pas de contrat
on travaille pas c'est c'est la vie
donc sous réserve on est des contrats on
s'est engagé et puis bah après oui il y
a des sanctions si on est si on n'est
pas à l'heure c'est normal que c'est
comme dans tout contrat il y a des
sanctions il y a des retards qui peuvent
être justifiés donc pas justifiés et ça
ça va jouer dans ce domaine là sur
l'économie de guerre je pense ça
s'applique pas à nous
je le dis très très honnêtement si je
dois accélérer je sais accélérer mais
vous le savez mieux quiconque l'État
souhaite pas accélérer pour des raisons
budgétaires dans le domaine des avions
de combat donc je pense que l'économie
de guerre ça se c'est surtout appliqué à
des matériels qui ont été catégorisés et
en simuler les munitions c'est vrai que
fabriquer des munitions il faut
augmenter les cadences terriblement donc
ça je vous laisse en parler avec nos
amis fabricants de munitions mais nous
ça nous concerne pas en termes de
cadence contrôle des coûts il y a tout
le temps quelqu'un chez nous qui
contrôle les coups alors je parle pas du
contrôle fiscal qui existe et c'est
normal et j'ai pas je critique pas mais
vous avez des contrôles a priori vous
avez des contrôles à postériori vous
avez des contrôles de tranches vous avez
des contrôles sur le développement bon
on a des contrôles tous les jours
d'ailleurs un jour faudra avoir un
contrôle pour contrôler le coût des
contrôles mais ça je c'est de l'humour
ne le mettez pas au compte rendu
je veux juste dire quand même que et je
le rappelle parce que je pense déjà
l'avoir dit si je parle de profitabilité
la profitabilité de nos amis américains
c'est grosso modo 15%. si vous êtes en
dessous de 15% vous mettez à risque
l'entreprise et donc vous mettez à
risque la défense américaine
le jour où on aura cette logique en
France je peux vous dire qu'on aura fait
des grands progrès
le but n'est pas d'être à faible
profitabilité le but c'est d'être
efficace et à bonne profitabilité est-ce
que l'État est plus efficace que
l'industrie pour fabriquer je vous
laisse la réflexion moi je pense qu'il
est quand même remarquable avoir réussi
à fabriquer un Rafale entièrement en
France à un prix qui
moins cher qu'un F-35 aujourd'hui alors
même que F35 est produit à quelques
milliers d'exemplaires alors que le
Rafale qui est une réussite les produits
qu'il y a quelques centaines
d'exemplaires avec des passages à
cadence inférieurs à zéro donc nous
avons une capacité à produire en France
qui est qui est au bon coup me
semble-t-il mais ça c'est ma vision donc
les contrôleurs seront là pour vérifier
ce que je dis mais je tiens à le à
l'exprimer
devant vous
sur
les questions de de technologie
des carbonations de civils j'en parlerai
pas là
alors dans la décarbonation d'ailleurs
je me suis exprimé il y a pas longtemps
j'étais hier à Genève
la décarbonation du secteur aérien dans
le civil c'est avant tout les fuels
alternatif je veux dire l'avion
hydrogène vous pouvez y croire et que
ceux qui croient mettre de l'argent
dedans ça sera pas mon cas
donc on est engagé tous sur la
décarbonation de l'aviation civile pour
2050 est-ce qu'il faut des carboner le
militaire je pense que le ministère de
désarmées réfléchit avant de choses les
véhicules au sol etc bien sûr
sur la viande de combat aujourd'hui un
avion de combat ce qui ça coûte
suffisamment cher à développer et à
fabriquer le but c'est qu'il soit
efficace c'est pas un problème de
décarbonation et je pense que le le
l'empreinte de CO2 des avions de combat
dans le monde bon si on arrêtait les
guerres on y gagnerait il y a pas
d'autres mais malheureusement ce qu'il
faut c'est des éviter et pour les éviter
il faut être prêt donc je ne vois pas de
décarbonation dans le domaine des avions
de combat
sur la peut-être pourront-ils utiliser
des fuel alternatifs on verra au bon
moment pourvu que ça dégrade pas les
performances parce que si vous pour des
raisons de décarbonation ou dégrader la
performance qui vous a coûté cher il y a
un moment donné il y a un problème de
cohérence sur l'intelligence
artificielle on y travaille
on y travaille déjà dans le cadre du
Rafale on attend Pascal parce que sinon
on est à des horizons bien bien trop
lointain
il faut être prudent dans le mot
intelligence artificielle
il faut pas confondre les algorithmes
voilà l'intelligence artificielle c'est
la machine qui apprend à elle-même c'est
les machines learning comme on dit
je pense pas qu'il soit bon de dire
qu'il faut que on ait une totale
capacité avec l'intelligence
artificielle de conduire des opérations
de guerre soyons prudents sur les termes
par contre compte tenu de la densité des
données qui petit à petit arrivent dans
les centres de commandement ou même chez
le pilote il faut arriver à faire des
des tris de toutes ces données là selon
ce que les opérationnels nous
demanderons de trier pour que le pilote
il il soit en capacité on a des pilotes
très capables mais quand même il y a un
moment donné le cerveau humain a des
restrictions donc
intelligence artificielle peut être
utilisée dans ce cadre là pour faire le
tri troisièmement dans le cadre des
drones quand la communication est
brouillée coupée il faut que le drone
puisse être capable de faire un salon de
choses soit continuer la mission si tel
l'homme la définit comme tel l'homme
dans la boucle soit rentrer à la maison
tout seul et là l'intelligence
artificielle dans ces domaines-là peut
être peut être intéressant et on l'a on
a fait des simulations chez nous à
Saint-Cloud qu'on a montré à la DGA nos
amis militaire pour justement montrer
l'intérêt et je pense qu'il faut
continuer à travailler sur ces
algorithmes mais en étant très prudent
sur le fait que c'est pas la machine qui
décide toute seule et vous avez le
devoir de l'expliquer vous aussi à nos
concitoyens pour qu'il n'y ait pas un
une peur d'interminateur développé par
les par les vilains industriels sur le
sur le sur le Scaff et le écoutez moi le
jour où la Grande-Bretagne fidèle alliée
de l'Amérique et le Japon non moins
fidèle allié de l'Amérique front en
avion de combat concurrent des
Américains ce jour-là effectivement je
m'inquiéterais je suis pas ok je vais
vous dire j'ai peut-être tort
et il faut être modeste dans le je suis
pas inquiète l'alliance qui est dans le
Scaff me paraît beaucoup plus sérieuse
que l'alliance qui est dans le Tempest
il y a des briques c'est vrai ça existe
est-ce qu'ils vont vraiment faire un
avion de combat concurrent des
Américains concurrents de ce que
pourrait être un jour le NGF et avec
quel budget vous voyez déjà nous on aura
du mal je suis voilà les anglais sont
meilleurs que nous en communication ça
j'ai pas de doute donc je suis prudent
maintenant fusionner ce qui a fait
tempête c'est déjà difficile de faire ce
qu'il y a pas 3
on peut fusionner les deux mais bon on
va se reposer les mêmes questions qui
est leader dans les dans le temps passe
c'est les Anglais dans le SCAP c'est les
Français donc système d'à côté vous avez
d'assaut tiens ça me rappelle une époque
où on travaillait sur le ce qui
s'appelait déjà le Scaff mais qui était
franco-anglais on avait commencé cette
discussion elle était pas facile mais
moi c'était mon idée à l'époque donc je
serai pas compte de travailler avec les
Britanniques sauf qu'on a fait autre
chose alors si on change tous les 5 ans
de d'hypothèses je peux vous dire qu'on
va gagner on va perdre 50 ou les 50
alors rajouter des gens au Scaff c'est
compliqué j'entends parler des Belges
bon ok très bien et je préconise de
faire un club F35 au sein du SCAF pour
développer
les avions les futurs avions européens
donc je pense qu'il faut être faut déjà
faire ce qu'on a dit qu'on ferait ça a
été pas facile on a fait le SCAF à 3 on
a une phase en B à faire à 3 on fait ça
puis j'espère qu'on fera la phase 2 qui
permettra de faire voler l'avion à trois
si on veut rajouter du monde les
discussions seront plus longues parce
que les partages que nous français on
n'est plus qu'à un tiers on a deux tiers
qui sont partis de l'autre côté donc à
force de rabioter je sais plus si on
aura biotrapage un bout des compétences
utiles bon après c'est l'État qui décide
donc on discutera le jour J
sur la PATMAR notre projet c'est un
projet de pour dériver un Falcon 10x qui
est en cours de développement qui a une
taille bien plus importante que nos
Falcon actuels puisqu'il a une capacité
de 7500 nautiques de ranch qui
évidemment satisfait la Marine nationale
en termes de volume et en termes de de
capacité qu'il faudrait adapter pour
être capable je rappelle que ce sera un
avion d'armes c'est un non seulement il
doit pouvoir chasser les sous-marins
mais il doit pouvoir tirer un certain
nombre d'armes donc évidemment on y
mettrait notre expérience je pense qu'on
est les seuls en Europe avoir une
expérience depuis
1958 ça fait quand même longtemps qu'on
est sur la patma on a eu des équipes
petites toutes petites mais qui ont été
capables de faire des avions comme la
télé 2 de le moderniser c'est le cas en
cours et donc on est on mettra ses
compétences historiques et qu'on a
encore aujourd'hui demain dans le 10x
d'autant que on a une petite expérience
aussi dans les Falcon de surveillance
pour être capable de etc alors en termes
de coopération je vous dirais mais là
aussi c'est un petit c'est un petit clin
d'oeil
hier je faisais un point avec mes amis
de Rolls-Royce qui sont le moteur du 10x
et qui sont exclusivement une équipe
allemande
Rolls-Royce dans le domaine des Business
Jet c'est une équipe d'allemand
design fabrication tout est le bureau
d'études étant est en Allemagne et la
fabrication des moteurs est
exclusivement en Allemagne donc vous
voyez avec un des X vous avez déjà un
avion français avec un moteur allemand
quoi dire d'autre je passe à l'autre
page pièce de rechange oui tout sur le
soutien alors à l'exportation cité de
Super Étendard sur sur l'Argentine
d'assaut sans débrouille avec ses
sous-traitants bien sûr mais aujourd'hui
encore il y a des mirages 3 qui volent
les mirages 3 c'est pas grave à l'état
je peux vous dire que c'est parce que on
a maintenu un petit flux on a organisé
aussi la récupération des avions qui
veulent plus pour être capable de
soutenir encore ces quelques avions
mirages je crois qu'il va aller encore
quelques mirages F1 qui volent au Maroc
par exemple donc là aussi le soutien est
fait par Dassault puisque les fins ne
veulent plus en France et les Mirage
froid non plus on soutient encore les
Alphajet pour la France mais aussi pour
des pays à l'étranger donc on fait ce
sujet là on le fait en bonne
intelligence avec l'État et les ateliers
de l'État ce qu'on appelle les anciens
Ayas
je partage le travail il y a des accords
entre nous sur la propriété
intellectuelle il y a aucun problème
là-dessus et donc de temps en temps ils
prennent le travail c'est
idem avec les moteurs sur les sur les
contrats verticales verticalisés c'est
sûr que la baisse de flotte n'est pas
une bonne chose pour le volume mais pour
nous qui faisons le soutien des avions
français et des avions export le volume
a augmenté donc il y a aucune il y a
aucune conséquence aujourd'hui pour la
France dans les contrats verticalisés
parce que nos volumes augmentant on peut
mieux s'organiser et je le rappelle
bien sûr qu'on met nos amis français en
priorité donc il y a pas de il y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir sur Ravel je
parlerai pas au nom des moteurs c'est à
eux assez exprimé sur le le fait que
voilà après ce qui marche bien à
l'export par rapport à la France c'est
simple c'est que nos amis étrangers sur
nos recommandations quand ils achètent
des avions ils achètent un stock de
rechange
les Français c'est plus difficile parce
que il y a des contraintes budgétaires
donc il y a des choix des arbitrages et
de temps en temps ils achètent moins de
rechange que nos amis étrangers et des
rechanges de base après vous avez le le
les réparations le flux qu'on organise
mais vous avez un stock de base qui
permet de et que on calcule pour pour
leur compte pour être capable de faire
face justement et d'avoir ces fameuses
disponibilités supérieures à 90% qu'on
observe dans tous les les pays
utilisateurs de Mirage 2000 ou de ou de
rafales
sur le système d'information je pourrais
malheureusement pas vous donner de
beaucoup d'informations
quand on est à l'étranger on a un
système d'information qu'on fait nous
pour le compte des clients où on
s'intègre dans des grands systèmes
d'information déjà existants chez nos
clients
sur la France sur le Rafale on a un
système que l'on apporte une brique
qu'on apporte et c'est l'État qui a son
grand système d'information donc c'est à
eux qu'il faut poser la question je sais
pas je sais pas y répondre mais il est
certain qu'aujourd'hui pour bien gérer
des stocks il faut le bon système
d'information ce qu'on fait dans le
cadre du Ravel c'est qu'on échange des
données avec nos amis opérationnels des
armées
qu'on a mis en place des systèmes
d'information commun
des accords sur le la propriété des
données si on est donné opérationnelles
ou des données de l'industriel pour que
tout ça soit soit
très fluide et on a de mis en place on
est en train de mettre en place des
cloud commun pour que justement ces
données puissent être échanger en toute
sécurité entre entre nous et l'État et
on utilise un Cloud souverain ça me
permet de faire une leçon de choses
c'est excusez moi le Cloud souverain
c'est celui qui ne dépend pas des
Américains nous on le fait parce qu'on a
de ce système avec nous
et les autres vont vous dire qu'il y a
des clouds de confiance le Cloud de
confiance ça utilise Microsoft ou ça
utilise Google ou ça utilise voilà alors
je sais pas où on place la confiance là
c'est un problème de vocabulaire nous
avec nos armées on joue le Cloud souvent
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qu'on
porte au niveau de l'Europe pour dire il
faut développer des clouds souvent en
Europe je ferme ma parenthèse
est-ce que j'ai oublié des des sujets me
semble pas
oui c'est pour ça
allez on passe aux questions minutes là
parce que j'ai une liste importante je
rappelle que j'ai encore deux rapports
par derrière donc allez Jacques le nez
allons-y et les réponses aussi évident
ce président le 28 avril dernier les
ministres de la Défense des pays
participants en j'appelle donc la France
l'Espagne et l'Allemagne au projet du
Scaff on laissait entendre que le
programme pourrait s'ouvrir d'autres
partenaires quel est votre opinion sur
cette potentiel ouverture du programme
qui a débuté il faut le rappeler en tant
que projet franco-allemand mais vous
avez donné votre avis là-dessus et par
ailleurs le prochain européen de
standardisation du combat aérien
collaboratif a été lancé en février
dernier par Dassault qui en est le
maître d'oeuvre pensez-vous que la
présence d'appareils produits aux
États-Unis FC F35 dans de nombreuses
flottes européennes que vous l'avez
souligné pourrait entraver ce processus
de création d'un standard européen et
notre positif nous étions avec nos
collègues au Caire la semaine passée
nous avons rencontré votre présentant
donc au Caire qui nous a parlé bien sûr
des lépreux programme notamment de
maintenance et notamment sur les mirages
et note aussi favorable nous avons
rencontré au ministère de la Défense les
interlocuteurs qui nous ont dit le plus
grand bien du Rafale et le F16 à côté
était un peu ridicule pour ne pas trahir
les propos qu'ils ont tenus
c'est pas venu pour rien Président c'est
bien allez on soit Bono
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président un sujet récurrent mais qui
peut prendre une certaine acuité dans le
cadre de la prochaine LPM c'est la
taxonomie financière elle accès aux
financement pour les industries de
défense et plus spécifiquement qu'en
est-il pour Dassault Aviation
merci François Ludovic est
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général merci pour
vos propos liminaires extrêmement précis
je voulais vous interroger vous avez
abordé à plusieurs reprises ce matin la
question de la souveraineté par
différents domaines le Cloud à l'instant
vous l'avez dit également peu de pays
peuvent se prévaloir de pouvoir
construire un avion de A à Z et pour
construire un bijou technologique tel
que le Rafale mais aussi d'autres avions
en les construisant encore une fois
quelques semis conducteurs près je pense
or un avion de guerre à 900 pour moi que
s'il est bien équipé et un avion c'était
un tout c'est une technologie un
savoir-faire d'excellents pilote mais
aussi un équipement et un armement alors
si vous n'avez pas une vision enfin un
lien direct avec l'armement moi la
question en tant que parlementaire
alsacien vous la voyez venir c'est par
rapport à manurin qui est un leader
mondial incontesté de la conception je
dis bien leader mondial incontesté de la
conception et de la fabrication de
machines comment vous en tant
qu'avionneur avec l'influence que vous
avez vous voyez une sorte de mise en
place de circuit court de la munition
parce qu'il est toujours regrettable
d'acheter de la munition à produite par
nos propres machines
merci Ronan merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président ça a été rappelé
le 28 avril dernier à Madrid a été
officiellement lancé le programme imbé
du Skaf qui en réalité avait démarré
plus tôt puisque c'était finalement une
opération de communication et on peut
regretter d'ailleurs que cette opération
de communication n'est pas vraiment
dépassée les frontières de l'Espagne ça
interroge d'ailleurs sur le les
prochaines opérations de communication
des phases à venir c'est déjà très
difficile de faire le scafa 3 on le sait
les piliers sont répartis et facteurs
déportés moteurs NGF capteur club de
combat cohérence globale furtivité et la
France a finalement la part qui est la
sienne tout élargissement reviendrait à
réduire cette part permettez-moi
simplement d'exprimer le souhait que ce
qui a été évoqué par le à la fois la
ministre de la défense espagnole et
notre ministre des armées en France
d'élargir ne va pas dans le bon sens
enfin puisque nous sommes dans la phase
1 B il faut se mettre d'accord avec
l'Allemagne et l'Espagne sur les
caractéristiques de l'avion dont vous
avez évidemment la responsabilité le NGF
le Next Generation Fighters avec la
question fondamentale qui est celle que
je vous pose pour la France c'est
d'abord la question de mener la capacité
de mener un raid nucléaire pour
l'Allemagne c'est la défense
aérienne et bien est-ce que c'est
volonté des états partisans du parti
oscaf peuvent être effectivement
compatibles et comment allez-vous
réussir à faire cette synthèse je vous
remercie merci Renaud Olivier Cadic
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci pour vos propos il va
falloir être plus connecté et moins
vulnérable avez-vous dit ce matin cet
objectif guide nos réflexions et c'est
la raison pour laquelle le président
Cambon a souhaité que notre Commission
évalue les efforts dédiés à la cyber de
manière transversale dans le cas de la
LPM j'aimerais poser une question pour
pouvoir compléter vos commentaires sur
la nécessité de Cloud souverain le
département de la Défense américain a
lancé une initiative en juillet 2022
pour un Claude de défense intitulé zero
trust reference architecture qui prévoit
d'associer les grands noms américains
comme Microsoft ou Amazon pensez-vous
que la LPM nous permet de disposer d'un
cloud de défense suffisamment sécurisé
au regard des investissements que les
États-Unis consacrent à cet objectif je
vous remercie merci Olivier Rachid temal
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de qui sont
d'abord vous avez commencé par expliquer
notamment à son de zones
géopolitiques John du planisphère où il
y avait effectivement une possibilité
pour la France d'avoir une influence
importante donc ma première question
c'est quels sont à ce stade vos
prévisions de vente
d'avions sur tel était pays donc là où
vous en êtes donc un point de ceinture
là
deuxième dans cette heure-là quel est
votre doctrine sur la question des
transferts de technologie
et j'ai une troisième question aussi
rapide qui est quel est votre doctrine
vous aussi sur la question des modalités
éventuelles d'un contrôle parlementaire
sur les ventes d'armes
merci Rachid enfin hugsory merci
président monsieur le Président je
compte poser la question que vous avez
évoquée tout à l'heure en disant que
vous ne sauriez répondre car la réponse
était du côté des militaires la Russie
et l'Ukraine n'utilise des avions des
hélicoptères que pour soutenir les
forces terrestres un niveau tactique
craignant de voler loin derrière les
lignes de front dans le cas de l'Armée
de l'Air ukrainienne cela s'explique
facilement par le manque d'avions de
combat le manque de pilote expérimenté
personnel au sol pour les Russes en
revanche ils sont à la fois les
compétences et les moyens mais il semble
incapable de monter une opération
aérienne complète c'est sans doute le
résultat d'une tactique utilisé par les
forces aériennes ukrainiennes depuis le
début de l'invasion qui ont été en
mesure de construire un système de
défense échelonnée à moyenne et courte
portée compte tenu de ce constat compte
tenu du temps long nécessaire pour
développer un nouvel avion ou un nouveau
système de combat quel est selon vous
l'avenir de la chasse telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
voilà puis je rajoute une petite
question d'actualité quel sentiment
portez-vous quel jugement portez-vous
sur la décision du Président de la
République de former des pilotes
ukrainiens et est-ce que cela prélude à
la livraison d'avions français de mirage
vraisemblablement à l'Ukraine la
dimension technique du sujet bien
évidemment
la parole pour répondre à tout ça
je rallume sur le combat collaboratif là
aussi il faut se faire attention au
vocabulaire donc le combat collaboratif
ce sont des avions qui mènent à raid et
qui sont liés entre eux de manière très
forte c'est-à-dire pratiquement les
calculateurs de chaque avion sont en
connexion et un avion peut tirer l'arme
de l'autre etc etc
aujourd'hui ceci ne peut se faire contre
rafales que dans une patrouille rafale
si vous avez un F-16 ou F35 vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça et je pense qu'on ne
fera pas par contre si vous avez un F-16
un F35 et que vous devez faire la guerre
ensemble ce qui peut se faire
à plusieurs endroits est-ce qu'il y a
déjà été fait dans le passé vous avez
une question d'interopérabilité
c'est-à-dire vous avez des liaisons de
données
pour pas être trop technique mais sur le
Rafale c'est la liaison 16 qui est une
liaison validée et développée par les
Américains et mis à la disposition de
l'OTAN que nous avons dans nos avions et
cet interopérabilité permet d'échanger
des pistes des informations entre les
avions de manière informatisée selon un
standard autant chez les avions sont
déjà avec ça donc on peut déjà
travailler avec un F-16
c'est plus difficile avec un F35 parce
que là les Américains de manière assez
surprenante on fait un standard
américain non notant donc c'est fermé
donc et quand on leur pose la question
ils disent ben pour être interopérable
avec moi c'est simple vous achetez des
F35 je caricature mais je vous garantis
que c'est à peine une caricature donc on
est passé d'interpabilité à
l'uniformisation en disant vous êtes mon
allié vous achetez des avions américains
et puis tout va bien ce qui est vrai ça
allait bien alors ce qui va moins bien
c'est comment ils font entre F35 et 22
comment les Britanniques vont faire
entre 1 € Fighter et un F-35 bon tout ça
voilà donc ça va passer par des par des
relais des avions relais mais si c'est
des avions relais il y a du temps et le
combat collaboratif c'est quelque chose
qui se fait dans la microseconde donc ça
passe pas par des relais ça passe pas
par les satellites c'est des liaisons
très très puissantes que nous avons
débuté développé dans le cadre du enfin
le F4 combat collaboratif donc oui pour
coopérer que vous avez américains pourvu
qu'on est un standard ensemble dans le
cadre du Scaff l'ambition c'est que les
avions européens travaillent entre eux
mais comme la majorité des avions
européens sont américains
la majorité des avions européens sont
américains d'origine américaine je
répète pour
l'éducation de des populations et le
la problématique se pose c'est un vrai
sujet je sais pas y répondre moi quand
dans ma jeunesse quand je suis rentré
chez Dassault je travaillais dans les
groupes d'interopérabilité à Bruxelles
au sein de l'OTAN pour dire voilà nous
français c'était une bagarre permanente
très dur avec nos amis américains mais
on arrivait à imposer quand même le fait
que si vous voulez qu'on soit vos alliés
il faut quand même ouvrir vos capacités
à l'interopérabilité ce qui se faisait à
l'époque ça s'est perdu je pense qu'il
faudra y revenir et c'est un des grands
sujets
du futur
c'est pour ça que mettre plus de pays
F-35 dans le Scaff je vois pas bien le
je vois pas bien le sujet moi mais bon
c'est mon côté un peu restrictif donc je
peux tout de suite traiter cette
problématique
pourquoi est-ce que je ferai de la place
à mes usines à mon bureau d'études à des
gens qui ont fait le choix du F35 à des
sociétés que j'ai vu agir derrière leur
gouvernement pour acheter du F35 donc je
vais enlever de l'emploi de France pour
aller le mettre dans des pays qui ont
fait le choix d'acheter de la capacité
du F35 sur le thème de dire ah mais oui
mais grâce à ça demain j'achèterai
européen oui c'est il y a que ceux qui
le disent qui peuvent le croire quand
même j'espère que personne n'est dupe du
fait que c'est pas parce qu'on fait une
coopération technologique que demain on
va pas acheter américain alors ça ça
renvoie la problématique de l'Europe de
la défense qui est un autre sujet qui
est le sujet est-ce que l'Europe
s'organise pour etc etc on est tous
favorables à ça mais ça prend quand même
un peu de temps et en attendant et je
pense qu'il mieux vauteux il faut tenir
donc je suis voilà on a trois pays qui
n'ont pas acheté du F-35 sauf que depuis
qu'on a démarré le Scaff l'Allemagne l'a
fait elle qu'elle l'a fait uniquement
parce que je rappelle ça aussi c'est
l'art de la répétition elle est obligée
par les Américains pour être capable de
tirer une un armement nucléaire
américain
à la main du président américain
d'acheter des 35 pour mener cette
mission et bien entendu est-ce que je
dis est public il y a rien de il y a
rien de secret bon je suis pas sûr que
ça soit le concept français chez même
sûr du contraire
ok ça ça ne gêne pas de faire une
coopération dans ce contexte là
puisqu'on a parlé de des problématiques
franco-allemande et les Espagnols pour
l'instant n'ont pas acheté de de
F-35 je rappelle qu'ils ont quand même
des 18 et qu'un jour ou l'autre faudra
remplacer les 18 donc si dans la
coopération de demain du Scaff on a plus
de pays pro F35 que de pays pro
indépendance ça peut poser question sur
la ce que vous avez dit mais ce n'est
pas mon sujet c'est le sujet de l'état
et c'est à l'État à l'évaluer je suis
sûr que vous avez vos votre opinion sur
le sujet et vous devrez le l'exprimer
moi je défends simplement le fait que
j'ai déjà accepté un tiers du travail
par rapport à trois tiers
il est en France les deux autres tiers
ne sont pas en France bon je pense qu'il
est quand même intéressant de de
continuer à poursuivre le fait de
développer vous avez parlé de l'export
si vous prenez le Rafale on est grosso
modo à plus d'export que d'avions
français enfin disons que pour
caricaturer on est à 55 ans ça veut dire
que j'avais 100% et c'est doublé par le
fait que et le travail vient en France
les
usines dont on parle les cadences 3
c'est en France ça fait travailler ce
clin Mérignac Biarritz
Istres Argonay dans voilà un petit peu
tous les territoires et ça c'est que
Dassault et derrière pareil avec nos
amis de safrante Thalès et les fameuses
400 entreprises on peut aussi penser que
demain comme il y aura plus d'Européens
qui achèteront des avions
on continuera à exporter parce que tous
les Européens sont prêts à exporter ça
fera encore plus de volume et donc le le
tiers au moins du tiers nous rapportera
autant que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
peut le penser on peut le croire moi
j'aimais des réserves sur le fait que ça
soit aussi simple que ça voilà donc je
suis pas très pour répondre aux
questions l'élargissement rapide c'est
déjà difficile aujourd'hui je répète ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on fait la
phase 1 B on obtient un contrat phase 2
avec les mêmes parce que sinon on
réouvrira tout le partage des tâches on
a bien les Espagnols pour un tiers
Indra et sont des gens à qui on a
beaucoup travaillé ils sont un peu
écrasés par Airbus en Espagne
j'entends dire on pourrait donner du
travail aux sociétés belges tout de
suite non moi je suis pas si on m'impose
je me battrai mais je vois pas pourquoi
je donnerai du travail au Belge
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre comme
comme question sur la cyber donc je me
suis exprimé oui le Cloud souvent ça
sera difficile pour la France de le
développer tout seul donc on opère très
fortement au sein de la Commission
européenne pour que y ait une prise de
conscience dans la volonté de d'outils
souveraineté moi je rentre pas dans le
débat de savoir si l'Europe est souvent
nous passionne ce que je crois savoir
c'est que la France est souraine et que
on peut développer des outils de
souveraineté en Europe donc un de ces
outils pourraient être le Cloud souvent
on en parle toujours des Gafa on a des
capacités en Europe et en France donc on
peut les utiliser pour sécuriser notre
code moi chez Dassault j'utilise un
Cloud qui en aucune manière n'est liée à
Google ou Amazon etc et dans le futur on
va s'assurer ça en Hard comment soft le
hard c'est d'avoir les d'avoir les
mémoires
chez moi je suis sûr de les protéger et
deuxièmement les logiciels je le
développerai avec quelqu'un de confiance
pour le coup qui n'est pas un club de
confiance qui est d'associé et on fera
un cadre souvent et on est en train de
faire un Cloud souverain dans lequel une
partie des industries de défense vient
naval group par exemple je pense que
c'est important parce que c'est les
scénreux etc etc bon donc j'espère que
la DGA soutiendra cette initiative et on
le fait déjà au titre des MC au Ravel
avec nos armées
transfert de
technologie
vous nous connaissez on est plutôt
restrictif donc
on peut mettre des technologies à
disposition d'un certain nombre de
programmes que ce soit pour l'export ou
pour le Scaff
mais nous y sommes très attachés donc on
fait attention de ne pas brader notre
technologie n'importe comment vous
pouvez compter
sur nous sur le cyberge je redis pardon
j'ai l'esprit de d'escaliers tout tient
à l'architecture c'est-à-dire que ne
croyez pas en achetant des des logiciels
de protection ça marche ça marche pas
après dans nos ordinateurs on avait tous
des Norton ça existe plus l'important
c'est que l'architecture du matériel
qu'on développe doit être natif pour
contrer ou retarder la protection de
contre les attaques être capable de les
détecter et de les traiter et croyez moi
c'est un vrai problème d'architecte et
pas simplement un problème de logiciel
de protection donc
ce tout ces domaines là avec nos amis de
Thalès ou d'associés on est dessus à
fond
qu'est-ce que j'ai Russie - Ukraine oui
les hélicoptères les avions de combat la
chasse moi j'ai tendance à vous dire si
je prends la France que je connais mieux
que d'autres pays
il y a la qualité du matériel c'est sûr
je veux pas dire le contraire c'est
d'ailleurs cette qualité de matériel
elle est issue de l'expression d'un
besoin opérationnel de nos armées puis à
l'utilisation l'utilisation par notre
armée de l'air ou notre marine ça fait
la différence et vous aussi vous
regardez les concepts d'emploi des
Russes c'est ça date de l'URSS c'est il
y a pas de il y a pas cette coordination
il n'y a pas ces ces contrôles tactiques
enfin les militaires vous en parlerai
mieux que moi je suis pas
compétent dans le domaine mais on voit
bien que déjà les modes d'utilisation
sont très différents maintenant
comprendre pourquoi l'un ou l'autre etc
quant aux Ukrainiens me semble-t-il sont
les pays occidentaux qui leur font leur
tactique donc ils bénéficient de tout ce
savoir-faire des pays des pays
occidentaux très certainement
anglo-américain en particulier
ça fait beaucoup la différence il y a
pas que le matériel il y a aussi
l'utilisation
opérationnelle la manière dont ça se
fait
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié à la taxonomie
alors la taxonomie je le dis en
proposiminaire elle a été mise de côté
ça peut être axonomie sociale donc
financière mais vous avez l'air du
bateau si j'osais m'exprimer dans
l'aviation donc dans toutes les
industries de défense vous êtes regardé
de travers par un certain nombre
d'investissements par un certain nombre
de banques même si les banques nous
disent le contraire aujourd'hui et je
les crois en France
il faut simplement redonner
ces lettres de fierté au fait que
contribuer à développer des matériels
dans un cadre qui est dicté par un
certain nombre de de gouvernants de pays
démocratiques
contrôlée par la démocratie il y a pas à
mon avis on devrait plutôt avoir des
médailles plutôt que de d'être montré du
doigt et analysons bien ceux qui nous
montre du doigt d'où viennent-ils qui
sont-il S
c'est ça voilà on serait on serait très
surpris par ceux qui de temps en temps
attaquent plutôt l'Europe que leur
propre pays pour si des personnes
voilà je sais pas de
[Musique]
perspective export oui ou pas très
bavard sur le sujet en général
l'Indonésie on a démarré avec 6 donc on
a on a 42 donc on va on va passer de 6 à
42 dans les dans les mois qui viennent
ça c'est le chez le grand travail de
l'année 2023 on attend aussi de la part
de nos amis indiens en annonce bon avec
l'un il faut être patient
donc on y travaille il y a d'autres pays
on a entendu parler d'un pays en
Amérique du Sud on a aussi lu dans le
Wall Street Journal qui n'est pas
journal européen ni français pas Figaro
que que ça commençait à Gasser les
Américains que Dassault vendent des
avions un peu partout bon moi ça m'agace
pas ils ont qu'à être meilleur que nous
mais bon voilà ils sont l'Amérique du
Sud ils y tiennent la Colombie ils
yiennent beaucoup
on a d'autres pays dans laquelle on
prospecte donc
je vais pas vous parler de pays en
particulier je vais vous dire qu'il y a
une un intérêt renforcé c'est ce que
j'ai appelé le succès appel le succès un
intérêt renforcé parce que l'utilisation
de ces avions en Inde dans un certain
nombre de pays en plus de nos
opérationnels démontrent qu'on a des
compétences des capacités et que c'est
pas simplement de la publicité de dire
que le Raphaël est un bon avion c'est un
bon avion c'est démontré et qu'en plus
vendu par un pays comme la France ça a
un sens
sur des partenariats stratégiques etc et
donc compte tenu de mon introduction sur
le fait que le monde n'est pas bipolaire
voilà on a des on a des perspectives
c'est vrai pour nous les avions c'est
vrai pour d'autres types de matériel
aussi comme le matériel naval
alors j'ai pas de commentaires parce que
là c'est vraiment
le Parlement et l'État
aujourd'hui il y a ce qu'on appelle la
sienne
à vous de voir avec l'État comment vous
voulez vous partager le contrôle moi je
peux merci moi je subis tous les
contrôles vous inquiétez pas j'en ai sur
d'autres qui vous aviez tous les jours
dans mes murs et des équipements
entières qui répondent à des questions
sur d'autres points vous avez des avis
même quand c'est pas forcément j'étais
juste d'avoir un avis
nous nous sommes sous l'interdiction de
vendre du matériel de guerre on nous
autorise à le vendre qui nous autorise
c'est l'état si l'État a besoin d'avoir
le seul la seule question du travail
parlementaire c'est que il faut qu'il
soit fait en discrétion parce que ce
sont des relations diplomatiques
compliquées mais ça c'est à vous de bien
l'organiser c'est et puis après
pourrait être trop perméable je le vois
trop à Bruxelles trop perméable aux
idées des ONG et n'oubliez pas que les
je suis pas contre les ONG je leur parle
mais les ONG qui sont payés par
certaines personnes pour venir casser
l'industrie en France on a le droit de
se défendre et j'espère que vous allez
nous défendre
absolument
pardon
pas du tout je
[Musique]
il y a pas de
doute c'est bien pour ça que je dis ça
oui mais
je vous ai pas parlé de
bah écoutez je dis ce que je pense et je
n'ai pas dit que les parlementaires
étaient des ONG je vous ai dit attention
et je vous ai parlé du Parlement
européen je vous ai pas parlé du Sénat
et Dieu sait
Gilbert si on peut garder ce
cette audition le but n'était pas de
vous agresser si tel était le cas je
j'en suis désolé mais voilà
alors
les munitions sont pas vraiment vas-y
vas-y non simplement Monsieur le
Directeur par rapport aux munitions
votre vision sur un marché plus national
plus local des munitions est-ce que il y
a une vraie question de fabrication de
quantité de munitions donc je pense que
ce domaine d'activité doit rester en
partie en France il y en a nous nous
travaillons beaucoup avec MBDA et avec
Safran sur le sur ces sujets là je
connais moi manurin parce que c'est du
terrestre et je suis pas directement
impliqué dedans mais enfin il y a quand
même les munitions des canons de Nexter
par exemple que nous utilisons je pense
que ça fait partie de la souveraineté
merci
juste je n'ai pas entendu la réponse sur
l'avenir la l'aviation de chasse au
regard de ce qui se passe en Ukraine
excusez-moi ma réponse était partielle
la l'aviation de combat
utilisée par une armée de l'air par
exemple aujourd'hui qui est en train de
passer du Mirage 2000 où tu rafale c'est
ça qui fait la différence donc
l'aviation de chasse de demain c'est ce
que les armées voudront bien en faire
donc nous on apporte des technologies on
apporte des solutions des architectures
et c'est à nos opérationnels à définir
et c'est ça le travail qui est fait dans
ce qu'on appelle le pilier 0 jusqu'à 4
par exemple mais que l'armée de l'air
alimente fortement et la marine aussi
d'ailleurs et donc cet avenir il est en
définition nous pour l'instant on est
dans le domaine des technologies sur les
furtivité sur l'aérodynamique sur donc
qui mènera vers des missions RR ou des
missions airsol de dans un réseau
connecté dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
donc c'est l'ensemble de ces briques
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça fait pour un
système complet en 2040 c'est en cours
de définition
ma question sur la formation des pilotes
Ukrainiens a été technique c'est quel
genre de formation donne-t-on à des
pilotes qui n'ont pas pour on sait pas
je sais pas ça c'est il faut demander à
je suppose à l'armée de l'air je sais
pas très bien bien ce président merci
merci infiniment de l'ensemble de ces de
ces précisions je crois qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de
de réalité à rappeler
[Musique]
comme d'abord je note évidemment que
d'assaut est très engagé à la fois sur
la modernisation des rafales vous l'avez
rappelé et puis évidemment sur cette sur
ce projet de Scaff si vous êtes
et sur la préparation évidemment du du
SCAF et les nouvelles que vous avez
données étaient plutôt meilleurs que ce
que nous avions entendu il y a quelques
mois
je crois que surtout la question qui se
pose et que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est bien effectivement vers quel
modèle d'armée nous souhaitons aller
parce que on voit bien que le contexte
international est en train de se
modifier avec
[Musique]
avec toujours des questions autour de
l'Ukraine
qui qui peuvent se poser donc merci en
tous les cas de nous avoir donné cette
vision d'un industriel leader dans son
domaine et encore une fois merci bravo
pour les beaux succès que vous avez
enregistré récemment car je pense que
c'est quand même à l'honneur du
savoir-faire français que ce que vous
que vous avez évoqué donc on va se
servir de toutes ces réflexions pour
alimenter nos rapporteurs et essayer de
faire une discussion d'organiser une
discussion la plus positive possible
lorsque ce texte important va nous
arriver merci président
et merci à Bruno